[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
des taxis volants dans le ciel parisien
et oui la fiction pourrait bientôt
devenir réalité un projet fait l'objet
en ce moment de nombreux essais et de
vrais voir le jour pour les Jeux
Olympiques de 2024 un sujet de via 95
dès le début de ce journal les fêtes de
fin d'année presque comme autrefois sans
masse et sans pandémie les marchés de
Noël retrouvent les foules néanmoins
vous le verrez avec via Occitanie à
Toulouse l'heure est désormais à la
sobriété énergétique une belle histoire
solidaire aussi dans ce journal celle de
71 propriétaires qui viennent d'acheter
ensemble une maison 400 mètres carrés
qui devrait abriter des personnes en
situation précaire un reportage à suivre
de TVA à Rennes et en fin de journal
nous prendrons la direction des
sous-sols de la ville de Troyes le cœur
de cette ville historique est parcourue
par plus de 200 caves un patrimoine
captivant et envoûtant pour quelques
passionnés suivis par la rédaction de
Canal 32 sur place
souvenez-vous c'était à l'aube de l'an
2000 nous rêvions alors de voitures
volantes et près de 25 ans plus tard la
réalité pourrait enfin dépasser le stade
de l'imaginaire grâce à des taxis
volants c'est le projet surprenant sur
lequel travaille notamment la région
Île-de-France et la RATP dans le cadre
des Jeux olympiques de 2024 un volcès en
conditions réelles a eu lieu récemment
sur un aérodrome français
hélicoptère qui endurent sur place toute
une série de tests depuis un an
précision et reportage d'Angélique
Boilet d'Elisa Zanetta pour via 95
baptisez vos lo City l'engin à mi-chemin
entre le drone et l'hélicoptère prend
son envol au-dessus des pistes de
l'aérodrome de Pontoise Cormeilles le
futur taxi volant surmonté de 18 rotors
effectuent un vol en conditions réelles
dans un espace aérien resté ouvert cette
première en Europe et l'aboutissement
d'une année de test dans le Val-d'Oise
menée par le constructeur aéronautique
allemand vos locoptère et ses
partenaires la région Île-de-France la
RATP et ADP jusqu'à maintenant on a
testé des briques on a testé
l'acoustique la dernière fois à Pontoise
en mars dernier on a testé le dialogue
avec la tour de contrôle en septembre
dernier là en assemble les briques
l'appareil décolle il s'insère dans le
trafic aérien l'objectif commun
transport les premiers passagers lors
des Jeux olympiques de 2024 avec une
dizaine de taxis volants déployés dans
le ciel francilien trois liaisons sont à
l'étude la première devrait relier Paris
et Versailles entre les liports d'ici
les Moulinaux et l'aérodrome de
Saint-Cyr-l'École la seconde connecte ré
les aéroports Charles de Gaulle et le
Bourget enfin la troisième permettrait
de partir de l'un de ces deux aéroports
vers l'est de Paris pour atterrir sur
une barge en face de la gare
d'Austerlitz aujourd'hui on a un
écosystème complet c'est à dire que là
vous voyez ce qui va se passer en 2024
c'est à dire ok j'arrive dans un verti
port soit sur un aéroport soit en
centre-ville je vais passer dans le
terminal je vais faire mes contrôle de
sécurité je vais attendre mon vol je
vais monter dans la machine je vais
partir telle qu'elle a volé tout à
l'heure et je vais me rendre à ma
destination ce test grandeur nature
reste suspendu à l'obtention de la
certification de l'Agence européenne de
sécurité aérienne si feu vert il y a en
2024 l'appareil 100% électrique ne
pourra transporter qu'un seul passager
avec un pilote à bord on est sur un
niveau d'émission proche de celui d'un
autobus conventionnel et à ce titre on
estime que il peut avoir sa place en
environnement urbain si
l'expérimentation est concluante des
engins autonomes sans pilotent
pourraient voler à l'horizon 2030 des
modèles plus grands également un
volocyty 6 places est actuellement testé
en Allemagne aucun tarif n'est pour leur
arrêté mais la volonté est de proposer
un prix comparable à une course VTC
voilà et qui sait peut-être bientôt
c'est le Père Noël qui livre aura ses
cadeaux grâce à l'un de ses engins
volants Noël justement parlons-en entre
la course aux cadeaux et les premiers
achats pour les repas de fête les
Français se préparent à se réunir en
famille rendez-vous incontournable de ce
mois de décembre les marchés de Noël
reviennent en force après les années
covid sans masque et sans distance la
préoccupation est désormais aux
économies d'énergie exemple à Toulouse
avec ce reportage d'Hervé Lise pour vie
Occitanie
du vin chaud et de l'aligot des
éclairages et du patinage pas de doute
le marché de Noël est bel et bien de
retour un rendez-vous annuel que ne
manque pas Toulouse et touristes à
chacun ses plaisirs les décorations le
vin chaud les odeurs voilà l'aligot est
bon il y a plein de petits artisans et
plein de choses chouettes à regarder ça
brille partout voilà c'est bien la magie
de Noël ça fait du bien je pense que
Noël c'est une parenthèse dans une année
et il faut qu'à m'en profiter une
parenthèse dans un contexte de crise
énergétique les 88 exposants installés
sur la place du Capitole vont devoir
s'adapter on a pas forcément le droit au
chauffage au gaz voilà donc on s'habille
un peu mieux et on va mettre des bonnes
chaussettes des bonnes chaussures et
voilà en cette période de Noël la
municipalité prend certaine mesure au
niveau de l'éclairage donc nous avons
100% de notre éclairage qui est un
éclairage LED et pour participer donc à
l'effort national nous avons décidé
effectivement de donner quand même aux
toulousain la joie de Noël tout en
rétrécissant un peu le temps
d'élimination c'est à dire qu'au lieu de
commencer ce soir ça commencera le 2
décembre pour terminer le 2 janvier et
nous éteindrons l'éclairage à 22h le
soir nouveautés cette année le marché de
Noël s’étend à toute la ville attraction
et chats les gourmands s'invite sur les
allées Jean Jaurès et sur les places du
sale et Saint-Pierre le marché de Noël
artisanal et solidaire lui retrouve les
allées Jules Guesde le 3 décembre
Michel Onfray était l'invité
exceptionnelle jeudi matin de l'émission
Face au territoire sur TV5 Monde
l'intellectuel est philosophe et
notamment revenu sur la place de
l'Occident à l'aune de l'actualité
internationale regardez cette extrait de
Michel enfred en face au territoire
selon vous Michel Onfray sur les mois à
venir durant les années à venir est-ce
que nous allons insister à un regain de
corrélation pour ainsi dire ou une
nouvelle corrélation entre la richesse
de l'État et la détention de ressources
naturelles par ce même état ou plutôt
l'élaboration d'un nouvel échiquier de
domination jusqu'à présent l'échiquier
domination nous porter vainqueur
occidentaux qu'en sera-t-il demain
vous avez parlé de l'Occident il faut
éclairer le concept parce que je pense
qu'il y a deux occidents il y a un vieil
Occident qui s'effondre c'est la France
et l'Europe ça c'est c'est un monde
ancien mais un autre Occident qui est le
monde judéo-chrétien sur la totalité de
la planète si on est l'argile cette
Europe on voit bien qu'on a beaucoup de
choses en commun avec l'Australie avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande avec les États-Unis
avec le Canada par exemple et si c'est
fini pour nous l'Europe ce que je pense
ça n'est pas fini pour les États-Unis et
vous savez aussi que les États-Unis
c'est un mouvement de la côte Est vers
la côte ouest c'est à dire que quand les
les migrants de l'époque les Européens
d'une certaine manière arrivent sur
cette côte y compris les Vikings quand
ils arrivent il y a 1000 ans et bien il
s'installe et puis il pousse des
populations autochtones il détruisent
les les Indiens qui sont là et ils
arrivent sur la côte ouest puis après il
y a plus rien et je pense que l'avenir
de l'Occident il est là-bas c'est à dire
côte ouest il est à San Francisco il est
à Los Angeles il est plus à Paris il est
sûrement pas en Europe
voilà face au territoire avec Michel
Onfray est à voir ou à revoir sur le
site internet de TV5 Monde et sur les
sites des partenaires de l'émission
Ouest-France Nice Matin France anti 20
minutes et Centre France la montagne
sans transition et si vous achetiez
votre maison avec 70 autres personnes
l'idée peut sembler surprenante c'est
pourtant bien le projet que mène
actuellement des habitants de Redon dans
l'Ille-et-Vilaine l'achat d'un pavillon
de 400 mètres carrés citoyens et
solidaires permettra à terme de créer
six logements indépendants pour héberger
des personnes sans papiers et précaires
les détails avec la rédaction de TVA à
Rennes sur place
imaginez une maison de 400 mètres carrés
gérés par 71 propriétaires c'est le pari
de la grande maison le projet commence
il y a plus d'un an et demi lorsqu’une
adhérente de l'association soutient
migrants Redon demande de l'aide pour
héberger une famille d'exilés elle
envoie un mail à tout son carnet
d'adresse et sans faire exprès à David
Laurent le lendemain je reçois une
réponse
j'avais prévu
d'acheter avec deux ou trois autres
investisseurs un logement sur Rennes
pour le mettre à la disposition
d'habitat humaniste
mais ton message
me fait réfléchir
dit pour moi ça change rien d'investir
sur le Pays de Redon avec une enveloppe
de 530 000 euros si logements autonome
seront créés deux appartements destinés
à des exilés sans papiers deux autres à
des personnes précaires et enfin de
seront loués au prix du marché et ça a
une utilité sociale une utilité
sociétale je dirais même parce qu'on
essaie aussi de faire bouger les lignes
on essaye aussi de dire à d'autres bah
vous pouvez faire pareil vous pouvez
tout à fait acheter un bâtiment acheter
une maison acheter un immeuble et de
rendre service à des gens qui n'ont pas
de qui n'ont pas de logement samedi
après-midi les cinq commissions de
travail se réunissent pour discuter de
l'aspect juridique économique technique
communication et ici de la vie dans la
grande maison moi ce qui me plaît
là-dedans c'est de voir tout se
collectif en fait qui porte et qui est
et puis de voir l'énergie qui est donnée
par certaines personnes je suis
absolument
ce qui est par ça les corrénovations
sera privilégiée pour les travaux une
buanderie un grand hangar et le jardin
de 2000 mètres carrés seront des espaces
partagés mis en location de la grande
maison prévue début 2024
voilà beau projet solidaire qui nous
conduit désormais dans la Sarthe ou une
dizaine de chefs ont dégainé couteau et
tabliers pour préparer une soupe
solidaire au menu citrouille butternut
et autres légumes de saison pour
l'occasion leur cuisine n'était rien
d'autre qu'un parc d'attraction vous
allez le voir un sujet de Florian
vosnach pour LMTV ça
c'est une cuisine un peu particulière au
coeur du Parc Papéa les chefs aiguisent
leur couteau pour s'attaquer au
nombreuses courges qui les attendent on
nous avait dit qu'on avait 250
potimarrons et on se retrouve avec 4000
potimarrons donc les chefs sont à
l'attache aujourd'hui car vous écoutez
bien que ça va prendre un peu de temps
pour découper vider et laver quand on
aura fini on ira déposer ça dans le
congélateur de Papéa pour pouvoir les
ressortir la semaine donc on y est on
fera des solutions avec une telle
quantité de cucurbitacées il va falloir
trouver des fourneaux assez grands je
vais me mettre en relation avec Monsieur
poisson qui est responsable des collèges
sur la Sarthe et j'espère qu'il nous
trouvera une cuisine adaptée pour
pouvoir concocter et cuisiner cette
cette soupe ce potage fois le jour grâce
aux courges exposées pendant Halloween
dans le parc on a l'habitude déjà de
faire des gestes sur les associations
que ce soit les restos du cœur ou le
Secours populaire etc on s'est dit on va
essayer de trouver une suite un peu
logique à cet événement donc on s'est
dit pourquoi pas justement offrir à une
association les citrouilles pour la
transformer l'expo en soupe ou les
données tout simplement aux gens la
soupe sera distribuée du 19 au 21
décembre place de la République au Mans
les 19 bonnes tables sartois seront
accompagnés des associations tarmac et
de la marotte 72
de la course à pied du VTT mais aussi du
canoë le raid des alizés vient de
s'achever en Martinique la course
solidaire entièrement féminine s'est
déroulée dans un décor époustouflant et
pour cette sixième édition l'événement
pouvait une nouvelle fois compter sur le
travail de très nombreux bénévoles
sécurité encadrement ou aide à
l'orientation une centaine de personnes
étaient présentes durant 5 jours sur le
terrain les coulisses de leur
investissement avec ce sujet de José le
Chartier pour via à TV en Martinique ils
vont longer la coque nous prolonger la
côte alors je sais pas à quel niveau ils
vont sortir dernière mise au point avant
le départ du raid Olivier vérifie chaque
poste et contrôle avec minutie que tout
est en place et qu'il ne manque de rien
sur les points de ravitaillement en 2018
l'association pala-jaye prend forme avec
en son sein des bénévoles et passionnés
de course en nature le but prêter main
forte aux organisations de course et
aider au bon fonctionnement des épreuves
et 20 20 bénévoles sur les
sur les comment s'appelle sur les
épreuves de trail en sachant que bon il
y a pas mal de pas mal d'intersections
d'autres bénévoles contribuent à la
bonne marche de l'événement Daniel fait
partie de ceux-là avant chaque épreuve
il place ses coéquipiers à des points
stratégiques afin d'assurer la sécurité
des concurrents
ok j'ai positionné le premier poste donc
encore des Nations avec la l'équipe de
la protection civile qui est chargée de
la sécurité de toute la manifestation
nous notre rôle c'est d'avertir s'il y a
un blessé si une victime alors on en est
avec les derniers
dernière une fois la mise en place de
l'équipe terminée Daniel réalise le
parcours en tant que cirfil et il ferme
la marche et encourage parfois les
participantes qui peinent à boucler la
course cet événement majeur du
calendrier permet aux participants du
raid de découvrir la Martinique sous
toutes ses formes et pour que la fête
soi-même le comité martiniquais du
tourisme mais tout en œuvre pour la
réussite de la manifestation nous sommes
donc très soucieux très vigilants que
l'organisation se fasse en collaboration
avec un ensemble de prestataires
martiniquais nous intervenons aussi sur
toute la phase de repérage et nous
sommes également très impliqués sur la
partie communication c'est ce
rayonnement médiatique quel apporte à la
Martinique au-delà de l'image balnéaire
qui est très très connue à travers le
monde la septième édition durait des
alizés à mobiliser près de 100 bénévoles
c'est l'une des conséquences imprévues
de la pandémie de covid-19 le retard
dans l'apprentissage de la natation chez
les plus jeunes un constat lié à l'arrêt
des leçons d'initiation à l'école à
Limoges une initiative vient d'être
lancée pour combler ce retard comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images de nos
partenaires sur place cet aliment une
vingtaine d'enfants de CM2 bénéficient
ainsi de séances gratuites pour
apprendre les bases de la natation
explication micro d'Alan Ruaud sur place
on s'est rendu compte que dans les
écoles en discutant avec certains
enseignants avec les collègues des APS
au niveau avait énormément baissé et
beaucoup d'enfants avaient pas pu
bénéficier de cours de natation pendant
deux ans et l'année dernière les
enseignants ont fait un retour en disant
que c'était assez catastrophique
donc du coup on s'est greffé dans
l'opération j'apprends à nager avec la
dragée nouvelle-aquitaine et on a pu
obtenir un soutien financier la dragée
pour monter cette opération auprès de 10
élèves de deux établissements scolaires
des CM2 CM2 pourquoi parce qu'en fait
l'année prochaine en 6e la natation
devient obligatoire
une transition vers le collège toute
trouvée qui nous amène dans un centre de
tri du groupe La Poste dans l'Oise une
visite des locaux était organisée pour
les élèves de 3e pendant trois jours une
vingtaine d'entre eux a pu arpenter les
coulisses de la plateforme une
découverte ponctuée des changes avec
quelques-uns des salariés de
l'entreprise et des courts théoriques
dispensés sur place l'opération visite à
promouvoir l'emploi local dans les
secteurs ou le recrutement reste
complexe l'occasion aussi vous allez le
voir de jeter un coup d'oeil dans les
coulisses de nos boîtes aux lettres
reportage de Jérémy houblon pour weyo TV
la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
quand la cassette est remplie au 3/4 on
la sort et on la met sur le ce
correspondant ces collégiens découvrent
le centre de tri postal de Rouen
aujourd'hui Stéphanie pilote de
production en dose pour eux la veste de
guide les gens pensent que le facteur à
sa quéquette est distribue le courrier
mais il voit pas ce qu'il y a en amont
il ne pense pas que ça passe dans des
machines alors ils arpentent les 24000
m² de cette plateforme plonge dans le
secret de ses salariés et leurs machines
qui traitent chaque jour près de 900 000
plis de quoi faire naître des vocations
ou presque vous verrez toi travailler
dans ce cet univers là
non je pense pas pas facile de séduire
et c'est pourtant tout l'enjeu de
l'opération entre les visites les cours
théoriques sont dispensés ici même sur
la plateforme l'immersion est totale ils
font des cours sur le sujet sur
l'entreprise en histoire-géo en français
en anglais en lien avec le vocabulaire
professionnel c'est une autre façon de
voir les de faire les cours quoi
surtout de favoriser l’emploi local ici
250 salariés officiers entre
organisations production démarche
qualité ou même ressources humaines
autant de secteurs qui peinent à
recruter il y a des métiers de terrain
voilà sur la production et on a tous nos
métiers supports c'est important que ces
élèves qui pour l'instant sont ne sont
qu'en troisième mais ils vont vite de
voir se projeter vers vers un avenir
puisse déjà avoir une vue sur les
différents métiers possibles porter un
autre regard sur l'industrie et ses
opportunités un exercice complexe dans
un contexte de chômage encore tendu sur
le grand roi il avoisine les 13%
voilà et le monde de l'entreprise était
également mise à l'honneur par les
mutuelles AXA lors de la soirée des
Trophées RSE pour la région Sud-Est une
soirée de gala organisée dans un site
médiéval comme vous le voyez sur ces
images pour mettre en avant et soutenir
financièrement des projets locaux
investis dans le champ social et
environnemental précision recueillies
par Alexandre Sebag sur place
nous sommes des assureurs et donc nous
pratiquons des valeurs et notamment nous
sommes là pour protéger des populations
et pour prévenir les risques c'est une
cérémonie qui est très importante pour
la région et c'est pour nous une grande
joie de pouvoir être ce vecteur de
communication vers le grand public sur
tout ce que font nos clients et tout ce
que font les Français en matière
d'initiative et de RSE
et puis lors de cette soirée ce sont
donc quatre projets qui ont été
récompensés pour leurs actions pour
l'environnement le développement
solidaire ou encore la prévention
écoutez à ce propos les lauréats de ces
trophées et bien en fait c'est notre
agent AXA qui nous a informé de cette
initiative la compétition RSE et il nous
a dit que notre activité avait toute sa
place donc on a candidaté de la
visibilité de la crédibilité auprès de
partenaires que je commence à avoir et à
développer et puis
financièrement je vais je vais pouvoir
apporter beaucoup de choses dans
l'application des nouvelles
fonctionnalités du contenu beaucoup plus
riche et travailler avec des partenaires
et vraiment c'est une super nouvelle
pour moi ce qui nous a poussé à
candidater à ce concours c'est d'essayer
de mettre en lumière toutes les actions
qu'on met en terme de d'impact
environnemental sur notre territoire la
décarbonation c'est une belle
opportunité d'être ici au Palais des
Papes dans un environnement magnifique
ça nous ouvre des ports une proximité
aussi pour notre association et tout ce
qu'on a fait depuis maintenant trois ans
et demi et bon évidemment pour avec la
somme d'argent qu'on a eu ça va surtout
nous aider de développer nos projets
d'un point de vue logistique parce que
on reste une petite association qui a
besoin de moyens aussi pour développer
des projets voilà et bravo bien sûr pour
leur beau projet d'une remise de prix à
une autre dans cette édition zoom à
présent sur l'auteur tunisien Yamen
Manai ce dernier vient de se voir
décerner le dixième prix de la
littérature arabe créée par la Fondation
Jean-Luc Lagardère et l'Institut du
monde arabe décrivain est ainsi
récompensé pour son roman bel abîme paru
aux éditions elisades un ouvrage dans
lequel il trace le parcours d'un
adolescent révolté dans la Tunisie des
banlieues populaires
de la lecture encore avec dans vos
kiosques cette fin de semaine ces
éditions spéciales du magazine Le Point
consacré à quatre des plus grandes
villes françaises et hebdomadaires
publient notamment un dossier consacré à
la sécurité à Montpellier la ville de
Nantes quant à elle est mise à l'honneur
pour ses succès économiques la capitale
du Nord Lille se prépare au
réchauffement climat nous dit
l’abdomadaire enfin dans l'édition
consacrée à la cité du vin le magazine
s'intéresse cette fois-ci à la propreté
urbaine Bordeaux est-elle une ville sale
s'interroge le point à lire également
une interview du maire écologiste de la
ville pierre urmique ces quatre éditions
spéciales sont à retrouver chez vos
marchands de journaux jusqu'au 6
décembre
près de Bordeaux justement restons-y
pour parler cela va de soi de
viticulture le monde de viticole qui se
modernise progressivement grâce à l'aide
des technologies des outils dit de
précision permettent notamment aux
professionnels de faire face aux aléas
climatiques et de limiter le recours aux
produits phytosanitaires alors
l'innovation est-elle l'avenir de nos
vignerons et les moments de réponse avec
ce sujet de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
Sud-Ouest en Gironde
signé la soirée il travaille pour cap
2020 depuis plusieurs années cette
société girondine imagine des solutions
technologiques pour aider les
viticulteurs ou les agriculteurs il
s'agit de leur donner notamment des
informations sur le risque agro
climatiques prises au plus près de leur
vignoble ce piège à insectes par exemple
sert à évaluer le risque d'attaque de
nuisibles comme le verre de la grappe
par exemple muni d'une caméra il compte
les insectes piégés on va les
reconnaître et on va envoyer ces
informations grâce à une carte SIM au
viticulteur ou au conseiller pour
l'informer quand est-ce que les
ravageurs arrivent sur le sur la
parcelle ces capteurs sont déployés sur
un même vignoble ou même à l'intérieur
d'une même parcelle les données
recueillies sont ensuite passées à la
moulinette du numérique cela permet
d'évaluer le risque cap 2020 en matière
de lancer un système similaire mais plus
dédié aux risques agro climatiques comme
le gel par exemple cette mini centrale
météo duplique qui a plusieurs
exemplaires sur une même parcelle permet
d'élaborer une cartographie précise des
risques de gel dans une même parcelle il
peut y avoir des hétérogénéités par
exemple si on doit allumer des bougies
sur le gel on a peut-être pas besoin
d'allumer ces bougies partout la lutte
contre le gel c'est aussi le but de se
piquer devine connecté sentinelle bardée
de capteurs en tout genre il mesure la
température de l'air du sol du sous-sol
ainsi que leur hygrométrie les données
prises par cet outil dans s'il y a 3 ans
permet d’anticiper un risque de gel avec
7 jours d'avance Coralie de bois et
viticultrice à montagne Saint-Émilion et
l'utilise ce piquet connecté depuis 3
ans maintenant elle en a installé une
douzaine sur les 30 hectares de son
vignoble une manière pour elle d'évaluer
le risque à gros climatique même si au
final c'est le viticulteur qui prend la
décision d'intervenir ou non et à quel
moment il le fait c'est lui qui va être
responsable il faut lui laisser quand
même
une maîtrise de son vignoble en tout cas
étant viticultrice c'est comme ça que je
l'entends et je veux prendre moi-même
les décisions chez moi ce piqué peut
même se connecter directement avec une
éolienne pour brasser du vent chaud
exactement sur les zones où l'on risque
de gel ou de maladies et le plus
important tous ces sous-titres
technologiques ne servent qu'au moment
des périodes guitaristes c'est-à-dire du
mois de mars jusqu'à la récolte
voilà et des bonnes bouteilles de vin
elles en ont sûrement abrité
quelques-unes par le passé les caves de
la ville de Troyes représentent un
patrimoine exceptionnel mais souvent
ignoré de ses habitants c'est justement
pour le sortir de son ombre naturel que
des passionnés se faufilent dans les
souterrains du centre-ville sur les
traces d'une histoire presque oubliée
visite guidée avec la rédaction de Canal
32 sur place
sous les pavés du centre-ville plus de
200 caves un patrimoine souterrain
encore méconnu depuis trois ans
Jean-Claude et Sylvie parcourent le
vieux 3 pour les recenser parce qu'on a
un sous-sol troyen très très riche on
construisait autrefois en hauteur mais
également dans les sous-sols on a un
sous-sol crayeux et on a des caves
magnifiques au milieu du 17e on avait
162 ateliers de tissage dans les caves
au 19e des métiers à tricoter étaient
installés également dans les caves à la
Seconde Guerre mondiale certaines caves
ont servi d'abris entière ce jour-là
Sylvie nous a ouvert les portes de 4
caves troyennes tout d'abord à l'hôtel
du lion noir à l'hôtel de l'élection et
au mortier d'or ce sont des casques
privées des caves essentiellement base
16ème siècle ce sont des caves qui ne
servent plus dernier arrêt ensuite au
sous-sol du restaurant l'Illustré rue
Champeau contrairement aux caves
précédentes celle-ci est aménagée il y a
deux niveaux de caves et ça a été très
très bien conçu enfin très bien restauré
très bien réhabilité dans l'esprit
justement que Jean-Claude et Sylvie ont
commencé leur recherche c'était en 2019
Jean-Claude
de restaurants à proximité ou de
magasins proximité c'est arrivé comme ça
en fait on s'est dit tous les deux qu'il
y avait malheureusement aucune
publication et on s'est dit que ce
serait peut-être bien de creuser un
petit peu et on aimerait bien se faire
accompagner de d'archéologues
d'historiens locaux parce que c'est un
gros gros travail qui nécessite
l'expertise de personnes confirmées
Jean-Claude et Sylvie espère pouvoir
publier un ouvrage au sujet de ce
patrimoine troyen oublié
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]